Desert power. This is only the beginning.
Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my dune breakdown video easter eggs i'll
talk about the ending and what's going on with the
franchise because obviously this is just part one
the movie itself felt like an amazing first
half of a season of television it would be
really weird if they did not do part two and give
us the rest of the story if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos and big spoiler warning for everything
that happens during dune part one so you've all
seen a version of dune or you've read the books
but as you saw from this movie there are a lot
of differences between this the original movie
the dune mini series and even a few minor changes
from the books but this movie like dune part 1 in
2021 is trying to be much more accurate to the
books than previous iterations the dune mini
series from the early 2000s also did try to be
very accurate to the books which is why it was
much much longer and that's also the reason why
they decided to break the story of the first book
into two different movies why they say dune part
1 at the beginning of this film but one of the
first big changes one of the first big easter eggs
and references is at the beginning of the movie
instead of doing the thing that the last couple
of movies the miniseries have done opening with
the narration from the books they opted instead
to open with the sardocar speaking about dreams
the special type of throat speaking
was a sarduakar speaking that message
dreams are messages from the deep the way they
use that phrase it means two different things
dreams are paul's visions and the deep as in
the deep desert the worms the spice is just
foreshadowing what's going to be happening
during part one him getting visions but it's
also about paul's ability to see the future and
also remember everything from the past through
genetic memory as part of his powers so not only
can he see potential futures he can also remember
everything that's ever happened so when the
sarduakar is saying dreams or messages from
the deep he's talking about deep as in the deep
past like the distant past he's getting messages
from the past in the phrase dreams are messages
from the deep is meant to be a metaphor for the
entire dune series not just for what's happening
in this first movie the idea that paul's going to
be influenced by the past and it will affect the
way that he uses his powers to lead humanity to
this better future that reverend mother mohammed
talked about so dreams as messages from the deep
is kind of meant to be a warning and a prophecy
at the same time for the entire dune series
like in future movies hopefully they wind
up making them children of dune god emperor
of dune messages from the deep takes a more
sinister connotation with other characters too
so that's why i say it's a metaphor for the
entire series not just for the stuff that's
happening in dune part 1. if you're a long time
fan of the book series you probably noticed a
lot of the production design language tried to
be much more accurate to original concept art
han zimmer did the music and the soundtrack was
amazing but the way they use different sounds
like the sound design of the movie in the
way they use that to tell the story is also
incredible the way they end things here is they
end just as paul is getting ready to join the
fremen and start to learn more of their customs
become one of them and then help train them to
become the most fearsome fighting force in the
universe teaching them the bene gesserit fighting
ways that he knows as well as teaching them the
secret house atreides fighting methods that makes
them so fearsome to the other forces like the
harkonnens like they talk about the atreides
being one of the most fearsome fighting forces
in the universe but then the sarduakar are like
hold my beer the idea being that when paul trains
them in the bene gesserit fighting techniques and
the house of tradie fighting techniques it makes
the fremen even better fighters than the sarduakar
but as you can see during some of the big fights
they have towards the end of the film once the
sardikar legions roll in even without the extra
fight training the fremen are still very fearsome
and able to kill most of the sarduakar but not
all of them there's also a really cool parallel
between the sorted car and the freman 2 because
the sardakar are also a pseudo-religious army of
zealots training in a similarly harsh environment
of salusa secundus even though we only visit there
briefly during the movie they want to show you
that it's incredibly harsh climate but in stark
contrast to the desert it's raining all the time
but seleucid secundus is basically the emperor's
prison planet all these sardocar that you see
strung up they're trained like this starting
around the age i think of like six or seven and
most of the people that enter training wind up
dying before the age of 11 or 12. their training
is so hardcore that the ones that do survive to
adulthood like these legions here are the most
fearsome fighters in the universe at least until
paul winds up training the fremen even more i
feel like this movie did a much better job of
hyping that up and getting that idea across than
the original dune movie or even the mini series
but what happens at the end here is that jessica
is able to one-up stilgar and even though he's
ready to give them sanctuary within their siege
jameis calls jessica out and paul has to fight for
her as her champion the knife that he's fighting
jamis with is a kris knife you see a couple of
them throughout the movie they're knives that are
fashioned from the teeth of the sand worms that's
why they call it the tooth of shyhalud the great
worm and the really cool thing that they did here
using paul's abilities is that jameis winds up
being the person in paul's recent visions that
he just had teaching him lessons about the desert
guiding him mentoring him even though paul winds
up being forced to kill him in the fight per the
freeman's customs so a lot of you ask how did
paul learn lessons through his visions through
his dreams of the future from jameis if jameis
died here in this fight there is no actual
time travel in the dune universe like nobody
physically travels backwards in time or forwards
in time paul's powers passed down to him through
his bloodline orchestrated by the bene gesserit
give him a measure of prescience when he's been
dreaming as rev mother mohammed explained to
him he's been dreaming versions of the future
but here's the thing paul can't predict the future
perfectly he told mohaim that not all the things
that he dreams wind up happening exactly as
he dreamed them that's why she gets so pissed
off with him and tells him i hope you live human
because your abilities have barely begun to awaken
if you remember the original movie that also plays
into that scene of the sleeper awakening paul
awakening his full powers but at this point in the
movie that hasn't happened yet so what's happening
here right before paul's fight with jameis is that
he's seeing a bunch of potential futures based
on actions that he's thinking about taking even
though they only show you some of his visions it's
implied that he has other visions all the time
as well so him having a vision of future jameis
teaching him the ways of the freeman was one of
the potential outcomes for this had he and jessica
acted differently during this encounter with
stillgar and the other fremen so it's implied that
in the timeline where jameis was alive to teach
him jameis had not challenged jessica or paul to
fight but he did obviously so the future changed
and paul was forced to kill him but paul was able
to benefit from the knowledge that he learned in
that potential timeline using his powers they'll
continue to play with this really cool concept in
the dune sequels paul viewing multiple potential
futures and having to deal with the problems that
comes with that ability because of the outcomes
of a bunch of different timelines are similar how
would you choose with paths to take which future
would you pursue it's a lot like doctor strange
during avengers infinity war with the time stone
he uses it to view 14 million different possible
timelines to find one where they're able to be
thanos for good in fines one so that's the path
they take side note too for all the marvel fans
out there yes josh brolin is playing guernie
halleck during the movie the war master of house
atreides he was thanos in the marvel universe
but the thing with paul atreides is that as a
potential kwisatz haderach his one job as ordained
by this whole bene gesserit breeding program
is to lead all of humanity on the golden path the
golden path is what the bene gesserit called their
concept of a perfect timeline like what is the
best timeline for humanity and they call that the
golden path so over thousands of years they try to
create this super being through a breeding program
they can see that perfect timeline and tell
everyone how to bring about those events
within the dunes series the term kwisatz haderach
literally translates to shortening of the way as
in finding a quicker way to a better future so
that's why they were trying to create this super
being i don't want to talk too much about the
story beyond dune part 2 because even though paul
does wind up drinking the water of life to fully
awaken his powers like we see during the original
dune movie the water of life being the bile of
the sand worms and it does amplify his powers
exponentially but dune part 2 if you haven't read
that first book or you never watched the original
movie is still very much focused on the immediate
problem the war between paul the freeman the
harkonnens and the emperor everything with paul
trying to reckon with the golden path timeline
doesn't really become a huge deal until the next
story after that children of dune god emperor of
dune and for the most part is actually paul's son
leto etredes ii who has to reckon with the golden
path and during the ending of dune part 1 during
this first movie they kind of foreshadow this paul
can see a version of the golden path this future
that the bene gesserit are looking for but during
this scene when they're in the tent paul starts
having this nightmare ranting about wars being
fought under his banner atrocities being committed
in his name all over the universe people being
slaughtered everywhere by his followers and it
frightens him he's horrified by it so in those
visions what he's seeing is one of the possible
iterations of the golden path timeline so he
actually becomes too afraid to pursue the golden
path himself he kind of runs from it because he
can't stand the thought of all this death and
destruction being done in his name like this
doesn't sound better this is worse if you've ever
heard anybody refer to the dune story as a warning
for the savior trope that's what they're talking
about and they really won't get into that till
the sequels i think till after dune part two like
if they make dune part four part five they do god
emperor of dune so that's why i say his son leto
atreides ii really has to deal with pursuing the
golden path and why paul isn't really the kwisatz
haderach that everyone thinks he is during the
dune movie or even dune part 2 it's really his son
who's the true kwitsats hattarak there's an easter
egg for that at the beginning of dune part 1. when
mohaim is coming to give him the test and jessica
kind of explains the whole concept of their
breeding program they say that we believe this
person that we're trying to create is very near
it's meant to be a bit of a misdirect because paul
is standing very near like oh he's meant to be
this powerful person but really it winds up being
his son to be this perfect being that they thought
they were creating but here's the thing mohaim
says that they have other irons in the fire like
if paul winds up dying we have other candidates
other prospects out there in the universe so
there are many other people who can have the
same type of powers to see potential futures and
have knowledge of the past but in most of these
other people the powers are much more limited
paul's sister for instance who's still a fetus
inside jessica's womb right now at the end of dune
part 1 also gains the same kind of powers when
jessica takes the water of life they cover some
of this during the original dune movie which was a
very different version of the dune book story and
kind of a speed run version of that first book
but talking about some of the other characters
about jason momoa's duncan idaho some of you
obviously know him as aquaman in the dc movies
or is khal drogo in a game of thrones universe
without letting the director know he actually
worked in the sly game of thrones easter egg for
one of these big fight scenes when the harkonnens
in the sarduakar are assaulting house of atreides
before he's taken off in the ship when they
filmed this scene jason mamoa had just watched
the game of thrones season eight finale and
because he played caldrogo during season one
and because of his character's relationship with
daenerys and his real-life friendship with emilia
clark while they were filming he dedicated his
fight to his khaleesi like he literally shouts
it out that fights for you khaleesi i just saw
the season finale of game of thrones last night
but the other cool thing here you may
have realized duncan winds up dying
during the events of the film
trying to fight the sarda car
and like i said start a car at this point in
the story are still the most fearsome fighting
force in the universe so the fact that duncan
is able to go so long against them and kill so
many of them just shows you how badass
he is but jason mamoa is not permadead
he did die here this body is dead but in the dune
universe there's this cool form of cloning called
golas so golas are clones created from the cells
of a person who has died and even though within
the dune story it happens all over the universe
all the time the practice is kind of frowned upon
but when someone creates a gola they give it all
the memories of the original person using genetic
memory and a form of conditioning so creating
a gola clone is like creating a semi-perfect
backup of a person but gola duncan doesn't really
become a huge character until god emperor of dune
i believe so it's going to be a while before we
see him come back and what's happening here as
they're walking out into the desert with chani and
the rest of the foremen is they're getting ready
to climb on one of the backs of the worms and ride
it to the next siege in this scene of him staring
at her like she says this is only the beginning
and you sort of get this close up on her face is
meant to be a reference back to the visions that
he was having of her at the beginning of the movie
this moment in the future came to pass exactly
as it did during his dream it just at the time
he didn't understand what it meant and now he does
understand in fact a lot of the scenes of chaney
at the beginning of the movie where he's dreaming
her these attacks on the hearken and ships
that's stuff that's going to be happening in the
later movies like you see him dreaming himself in
the armor fighting the harkonnen troops so even at
the beginning of part one they're already showing
you scenes that are going to be happening during
part two but like i said the next big thing that's
going to be happening is paul learning the ways
of the fremen becoming one of them starting his
relationship with chaney then helping teach the
bene gesserit the house atreides secret fighting
techniques to the fremen to make them even more
powerful than the sardakar then paul orchestrating
his original plan that he had before everything
went down to cease all this hostility in the
universe between the harkonnen's, the emperor by
marrying the emperor's daughter princess arroulan
we haven't met her yet so i'm assuming they'll
introduce her in part two also introducing fayd
harkonnen because he's a pretty big character but
they don't feature him anywhere during part one
fayd is the baron's other nephew in rabban's
the beast's younger brother i don't know who
they've cast to play that character but they'll
probably announce it once they announce the sequel
the thing about fade is that the baron actually
views him as his true successor since the baron
himself doesn't have any children of his own that
he recognizes at this point in the story fate and
ruban are the children of the baron's brother who
i believe was actually ahead of him in the line
of succession but then abdicated his position so
the baron wound up inheriting his family's title
i don't want to get too far ahead of the story but
we'll also learn in part two about how the bene
gesserit manipulated the baron when he was younger
in service of their breeding program because the
baron does have children and grandchildren now
it's just that he doesn't know about them also
really cool detail too that they don't get into
in part one but you see the baron there he looks
kind of like this floating mass of flesh like
what happened to him because he actually used
to look kind of like fade when he was younger he
used to be this very beautiful looking man the
reason why he looks like this why his body just
degenerated into this lump of flesh is because
of something that reverend mother mohaym did to
him when he was younger as a form of revenge it
is all part of this grand breeding program of
theirs so we'll talk more about that when they
drop a trailer for dune part two hopefully they'll
announce that movie and we'll wind up seeing it
within the next couple of years but it's gonna
be a while obviously before they start making it
but if you have any big questions about the
story or any big twists or what's going on
just write them below in the comments and i'll try
to answer them in the comments marvel is releasing
the eternals movie really soon so i'll be doing a
bunch of videos for that make sure you have alerts
enabled so you don't miss anything everyone click
here for my new eternals doctor strange trailer
video and easter eggs and click here for my new
spiderman no way home trailer video and easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!